okay question to you guys have there
been any videos that you've ever
regretted or like you just come on my
first fully part of YouTube my first
four I okay I'm gonna say this but I
know it's not true III looking back I
feel like I hated it but I know yeah
right I enjoyed what I used to make but
yeah it was never what I wanted to make
yeah I made one or two things that I did
want to make and then I made more of
that until I got stuck making only like
about less stuff right yeah right and
that was a nightmare to get out of ya
just like anything I made that wasn't
Black Butler no one watched it no I
remember I remember I moved to London
and I was making like 1500 pounds a
month right yeah which in London this is
before tax by describe him I was
basically scraping by and iron bed this
is I for some reason I was adamant I'm
like I'm not [ __ ] making these black
bomber videos I'm not making them all
the [ __ ] time yeah yeah yeah and that
all of them bombed like straight up all
thumbs bombed I was getting like 1/3 the
views are not only getting and I'm like
I'm gonna go homeless I don't have to go
back to my parents and be like [ __ ] up
but you know I was persistent I was like
no I'm not I'm gonna make this [ __ ]
work yeah funny
I think that better than my old stuff
yeah and eventually it did take off but
I remember like I cuz the reason why I I
realized I had to change was because
someone told me they were like oh that's
weird that you can't watch your own
videos like at all
like even reviewing it I thought I
couldn't review them how do someone else
review them for me alright it was like I
would cringe too much Washington yeah
yeah cuz I didn't like it yeah I get
exactly the same feeling sometimes yeah
but like now when I make a good video
I'm like I [ __ ] love this part I love
that guy's hilarious
i watch is like you watch it like two or
three times before it goes I'm so happy
with what I'm making right now yeah
feels like a whole like I just been like
unchanged you know what I mean yeah
but it's hard and I see a lot of
youtubers and I remember cuz I used to
help out with a lot of comic and others
who would dub like undertale comics
alright yeah with that when I was the
thing oh yeah of course
haha yeah people who would dub comics it
was so easy to get hundreds of thousands
of views when I visit these young
fandoms they would get to like 200k sobs
they want to start branching out boom
none of the videos would get views yeah
and I was like I was trying to help them
but a lot of people when they get one or
two videos that do bad or perform poorly
they're immediately put off yeah yeah
anything else yes I like it just doesn't
do well it just doesn't do well they
don't want to figure out how to make it
work like cuz it is basically starting
from zero yeah a little bit of an
advantage all right but you basically do
have to kind of get rid of all your old
audience and get a new one it's probably
less discouraging starting from zero
because at least from my see no there's
nothing to lose you know and I like my
number one piece of advice from the get
garrus make what you want don't make
what gets views not exactly and I [ __ ]
myself over I'm lucky cuz I'm I think
I'm like one of tho one out of a hundred
right who managed to change yeah yeah
very very important get away from it I I
was persistent I did not start I I was
kind of in a similar situation not to
the extent of you with Black Butler but
I was kind of there when I did a lot of
corpse party stuff right yeah yeah yeah
because I originally blow up playing I
think it's cold spotty too which was
like the new cold sweaty game that just
come out it's only in Japanese so I the
first let's play the first let's play I
ever did is why I remember it was like
month it's like I just immediately blew
off because it was yeah you know how
dedicated the Corpse Party fanbase was
back then and it got to the point where
I would do course 42 it would just get
insane amount of views like way way more
than any of my anime content right and
then I found a corpse party spin-off
visual novel which no one also did
because there's only Japanese I did like
30 episodes of that all the episodes for
[ __ ] killed it yeah and it got to the
point where any other video I did during
that period I'd say like over 90 percent
of the comments were filled with coals
pot ERP is yeah like replying to each
other's comments body characters and and
and I looked at that I was like I care
I shouldn't get stuck you this is I
gotta get out I gotta get out of here
and I can get the [ __ ] out oh yeah and
one thing I tell other youtubers who are
like maybe I like 10 to 50,000
yeah a stock you know content where they
can't get out of it yeah it's the only
content that gets fused by doing a
certain amount of thing over and over
again like you know like a pet almost
right yeah I do the thing you did but
differently slightly yeah I always tell
them like think of it this way like
maybe if you changed your videos up
entirely the the 50,000 subscribers that
you're so desperately clinging on to
right now could be a million yeah I'd
like don't worry about the subscribers
you have because most of them probably
only care about that one thing right and
if you want to change you don't need
this subscribers change all the time
they please recycle subscribers don't
really mean much in terms of view counts
and nowadays because it's all about
recommended and what 300 can we like
breaking okay how is that happening and
it's like I know YouTube used to be able
to show you how do people unsub from her
channel they removed it but they used to
show you and I remember at like 600 K it
was like plus six hundred thousand
subscribers minus eighty thousand yeah
yeah you will siphon out people in a
good way yeah you'll lose the audience
you don't want and that's okay but it's
hard to teach people that because I get
you choose heart because all they see is
then minus eighty thousand they think oh
I could be at six hundred and eighty
thousand oh no cuz like for me I part of
the reason I feel like I've been able to
be on the staffing for so long is that I
always like try to change my con
it's always like a conscious effort at
this point so like if I look at my
content last year and I'm making exactly
the same console like not like I don't
feel like you have to do like a big
[ __ ] change straightaway but if you
like gradually change over the years
it'll it'll be totally [ __ ] different
cuz like time if you look at my content
five years ago totally different than I
do now but the work the way you
implement that you do things a little
bit at a time so how I see it is if I'm
doing exactly the same content as I'm
doing last year to me I failed
oh yeah I've I've personally failed
myself like I remember last year I was
like it was probably like my best
overall year into
of views on my channel and I was
actually like I was really unhappy with
my channel because I'm like this is
exactly the same stuff I've been making
last year for the for an entire year and
you it hurt me it like hurt me but like
I didn't know what I wanted to do next
so it took me like a little bit longer
to figure out okay I want to try
something different in this way and that
way but it's it's part of the secret of
like being able to survive on YouTube
for so long evolving oh yeah it's like
you have to constantly be looking for
that yeah that's the scariest thing
right is that there's nothing scarier
than YouTube viewers losing interest in
a YouTube channel then the actual
YouTube losing used in the YouTube
channel
I feel like you've really upped your
game in like the past year oh no you
have I definitely have I mean I think
like late late 2019 like 2019 for me was
a weed year because at the beginning of
2019 I was kind of in the same boat
where I just kind of looked at my
channel I thought this is the same [ __ ]
I've been doing since I moved to Japan
yeah just like yeah so yeah I mean I
think late 2019 was where I was like you
know what I'm gonna kind of slow down on
the analytical stuff like you do way
less scripted [ __ ] and kind of just do
more fun entertainment-based yeah I
don't have to always be like the big
brain warrior yeah I feel like we all
rubbed off on each other
almost I think definitely moving here
I've liked seeing how you guys work has
like given me like a different
perspective about how content can be
made and like different approaches cuz I
feel like a lot of a lot of people when
they think about making their content
better they're like okay like maybe
getting better equipment or there's
definitely a factor of that yeah yeah
and there is a factor of that or like
some sometimes it's like oh I gotta
increase make my writing better and you
know do this but sometimes it's just
what up what if you just try approaching
your content in a completely in a
completely different way yeah but I mean
we're going back to an issue where
everyone tries to make content to appeal
to each other as they what I see is
content being approached exactly the
same way oh yeah different it's all
saying it's just a decoration upon each
other like I don't they don't do
anything differ
which is which is why it I find a way to
buy the tearless because yeah I can
definitely see how you might find X
content better but to me it's like okay
well you're still like approaching in
the same way someone someone might have
better editing or better writing or just
better idea or more interesting
but it's still kind of like in the same
the same knee should I say yes they can
vacant but they'll sit here and then
talk about you know like I remember like
I don't know which means you were was
they are they like they're like yeah his
his clips election was poor and I'm like
who the [ __ ] who cares about his clique
who watches a video of an anime review
news like this clip selection is rather
dramatic yeah you know you don't think
that you're like if the video is at that
point where you're nitpicking that much
I feel like that you know Montana State
yeah yeah this is that egregious right
well yeah blip selection is that poor
right it shouldn't be a factor yeah it's
not what when you're talking about anime
picking the right clips doesn't [ __ ]
matter it's what you're talking about as
long as the clips not in 240p no one
gives us I mean which is why like I
don't know like personally the thing
that I've tried to improve the most on
is like how comfortable I am on camera
I'm always trying to like pop it yeah I
want to make it feel like it's just like
my best friend in the room yeah how you
doing yeah